[Música]
spectrum
dicen que si juzgamos a un pez por su
habilidad para preparar boles siempre
pensará que es un tonto
cuántas veces nosotros hemos sentido que
no tenemos ciertas capacidades que no
somos suficientes que no nos estamos
haciendo bien la mayoría de estas veces
es porque nos esforzamos demasiado por
hacer algo para lo que no somos buenos
por hacer algo que nos dijeron que
teníamos que hacer por hacer algo que le
funciona a otros o por hacer algo que
nos dijeron que era necesario para
encajar en una sociedad y es que de eso
se trata este juego de esos moldes que
hacen ciudadanos todos iguales que su
éxito se mide por los mismos parámetros
y que la viabilidad de su vida en
sociedad está regida por que sigan las
instrucciones para vivir en el espacio
donde nacieron estudia trabaja al dinero
cásate pero cuidado tienes que estudiar
la carrera adecuada hacer la cantidad de
dinero que otros esperan de ti casarte
con la persona que debe es casarte con
la que otros esperan que hagas una
y después tener hijos cuantos los que
son adecuados para tu sociedad los que
son adecuados para tus padres para tus
tíos para tu ciudad no más porque eso ya
es demasiado no menos porque hay algo
raro si no tienes hijos a cierta edad
todo esto se trata de un molde como si
todos fuéramos exactamente iguales y
desde pequeños como dicen los cabalistas
que conocemos las emociones por su
opuesto conocemos la felicidad por medio
de la tristeza pero las emociones de las
que más el ser humano necesita es la
conexión la aceptación y la pertenencia
no somos muy niños inmediatamente
conocemos la desconexión el rechazo y la
no pertenencia porque porque si un niño
es muy bueno para las matemáticas pero
muy malo para historia y geografía que
crees que va a pasar claro lo van a
poner a estudiar historia y geografía
sin importar que puede ser un genio
matemático van a enseñarle para lo que
bueno van a llenar su vida de historia y
geografía van a llenar sus tardes de
clases de regularización de historia o
geografía la conversación en los fines
de semana cuando llegue la familia va a
ser que es un niño que no sabe de
historia y geografía y los maestros de
historia geografía van a tener el ojo
puesto en ese niño que sabe que tiene
una deficiencia cuando para nada es
puede ser un genio matemático o por el
contrario puede no dar una en matemática
así que crees no lo necesita y
deberíamos de estar haciendo realmente
lo contrario si un niño es muy bueno
para algo eso es lo que debemos de
fomentar eso es lo que tenemos que
ponerle a la mano cómo hacemos para que
desarrolle sus capacidades al máximo y
olvidemos de los niños son los jóvenes
qué pasa con personas de 30 40 50 o 60
años que llevan una vida miserable y
cuando hacemos la vida miserable hablo
de que podrían su trabajo podrían los
lunes odian a su jefe odian lo que hacen
o bien prácticamente su vida un poco se
ponen de buenas el viernes el sábado más
o menos lo disfrutan pero el domingo se
vuelven a deprimir porque mañana es
lunes este es un componente de muchas
cosas primero de tratar de llenar ese
molde en el que nos metieron y al que
nos dijeron que teníamos
a cumplir ciertas expectativas y otras
estar lejos de nuestro talento insistir
en las clases de matemáticas que no son
para nosotros esforzarnos demasiado por
ser alguien que nunca vamos a llegar a
ser y lo peor de todo es que todo esto
que te acabo de decir va en contra de
las leyes universales en contra de todas
las leyes de la naturaleza porque la
naturaleza no se comporta así y volvemos
a esta historia del peso y si le pides
que trepe un árbol seguramente no nos
vas a sentir un poquito se va a morir
fuera del agua sin embargo está en el
mar o está en el estanque y literal como
pez en el agua la naturaleza se comporta
de manera completamente distinta a cómo
queremos encasillar el talento del ser
humano un pez no se esfuerza por nada no
intenta nadar no aprende a nadar no
estudia nadar no toma clases de
regularización para nada simplemente
siente el agua
nada vive existe disfruta fluye un ave
no intenta volar no estudia volar nos
espera por volar nueva clase de
regularización para volar
simplemente extiende sus alas y vuela y
es majestuoso y es extraordinario verlo
y una de las aves más hermosas es el
águila pero imagínate que le pidieras a
un águila que deje de volar que por
favor deje sus locuras y empiece a
trepar un árbol con sus patas tan
débiles y con su cuerpo tan grande y
pesado que no le permitieran volar que
la obligara a caminar en el campo además
de volverse vulnerable seguramente sería
agotador eso no es vida eso es estar de
lunes a viernes en un trabajo que odia
eso es permanecer casado en una relación
que no es sana eso es tener un montón de
hijos cuando ni siquiera tienes el
tiempo para dedicarles eso es obligar a
un
a estarse en pie y hablando de la
naturaleza y de esta ley del menor
esfuerzo que es la que rige los planetas
y los satélites la luna no se esfuerza
por estar cerca de la tierra simplemente
órbita alrededor de la tierra
absolutamente natural hablemos de uno de
los animales más pequeños vulnerables
pero también de los más hermosos porque
aquí voy a hablar de otra ley universal
que es la ley de la compensación
imaginen a una pequeña oro una pequeña
oruga que todo el tiempo ha estado entre
las hojas trepando a árboles ellas y de
manera muy cómoda de repente un día al
despertar de un largo sueño se da cuenta
que esa forma en la que siempre vivió de
escalar cómodamente un árbol ya no está
sucede de repente escalar ese algo y se
está volviendo muy complicado hay algo
en su espalda y no entiende que pero
algo que le pesa tremendamente y que no
le permite moverse con facilidad ese
algo se llaman sus alas a cuatro de
nosotros en algún momento de la vida nos
ha pesado el talento que llevamos
cargando porque nos obligan a movernos
de una forma que no es natural entre
nosotros en lugar de extender las alas y
volar la mariposa pelea
con su talento índice y yo tengo que
seguir preparando árboles porque esto es
lo que siempre he hecho sin darse cuenta
que eso que siempre ha hecho va
absolutamente en contra de su naturaleza
tiene un talento y además tiene una
superioridad física que no todos los
animales tenemos puede volar sin embargo
es un animal de los más vulnerables y
frágiles de todo el reino animal
yo diría que para la mariposa
prácticamente todos los animales somos
depredadores por su vulnerabilidad y su
fragilidad sin embargo tiene esta
habilidad además de esta superioridad
física que es poder volar y no sólo eso
sino poderse camuflajear con otros
animales con las plantas con los árboles
con prácticamente todas las naturales y
es que la ley de la compensación nos
dice que no importa que tan vulnerable
parezca es que tan pequeño parezcas si
logras encontrar cuál es tu talento si
logras en lugar de que pp ese saber que
esas son tus alas
entonces vas a tener una tremenda vida
no voy a hablar de una superioridad
aunque en el caso de la mariposa así lo
mencioné pero en realidad es que cuando
encuentras tu talento la competencia se
acaba porque ya no tienes que competir
con otros por entrar en el molde tu
molde es único has encontrado tu fórmula
personal del éxito lo que tú haces te
hace extraordinariamente bueno y lo
haces de una forma que nadie más lo va a
poder hacer
así es que hoy te digo encuentra tu
talento identifica lo y ojo esto es un
tema científico esto es un tema de
ciencia esto no es un tema de lo que más
me gusta hacer porque yo he escuchado a
muchas personas decir haz lo que te
apasione y cuando te apasionas nunca más
tienes que trabajar y yo te puedo decir
que a ti te puede apasiona jugar fútbol
pero posiblemente es muy malo para los
deportes o que quizá te apasione cantar
pero cuando tú cantas todos los demás
quisiéramos nunca escucharte entonces
que se trata de lo que más te gusta lo
que más te gusta puede ser tu hobby
puede ser mucha diversión pero eso no
necesariamente va a hacer tu talento tu
talento es algo que haces
extraordinariamente bien y la pasión es
algo que surge de la satisfacción de la
tarea bien hecha del trabajo completado
de decir lo logramos y además me siento
bien en el camino no importa lo que
estés haciendo en este momento no
importa cuál sea la profesión que
escogiste o cuál sea la vida que estás
teniendo en este momento una cosa así te
voy a decir si te está costando mucho
trabajo si te tienes que esforzar por
ser quien otros quieren que seas o te
tienes que esforzar por satisfacer las
expectativas de otros si tienes que
estudiar demasiado y tienes que luchar
por ser una persona seguramente esa
persona no eres tú seguramente solamente
tienes que
carl dónde está tu talento y esas son
tus alas esas que tienes que soltar para
poder volar no limitarte en un molde al
que definitivamente no perteneces hay
algo curioso yo tengo muchos años
estudiando el talento muchas largas
investigaciones me he encontrado que no
existe un solo autor que defina cuáles
son exactamente los talentos
yo me dado la tarea de definir algunos
que me parecen que la vida sin ellos sin
esos seres que tienen estos
extraordinarios talentos estas
capacidades extraordinarias la vida sin
ellos no tendría sentido pero
curiosamente hay pocas personas que le
den importancia al talento hay algunos
que se han atrevido a decir que la
disciplina siempre derrotará al talento
y yo tengo esta pregunta para ti si tú
crees que la disciplina siempre
derrotará al talento porque crees que
hay algo que tenga que derrotar al
talento no sería mucho mejor tener un
talento con disciplina claros en
silencio mientras admiramos la magia
porque tendría yo que exigirle
disciplina
y pedirle a rodar que tenga un horario
de 8 a 5 porque así lo marcan las buenas
costumbres y una más para de una vez
terminar con esta teoría cuántas horas
cuánta disciplina y cuánto estudio crees
que nos haría falta a ti oa mí para
emular la genialidad de tesla de
einstein de algunos comunicadores
contemporáneos de algunos otros del
mundo del entretenimiento
he visto ejemplos de disciplina
derrotando al talento y ese ejemplo de
disciplina derrotando el talento una y
otra vez son estas historias de
sufrimiento de derrotas de fracasos de
esfuerzo inhumano de me esforcé toda mi
vida y sólo así lo logré no sería mucho
mejor decir identifique para que soy
bueno por supuesto estudie por supuesto
lo desarrolle al máximo y cres incluso
me divertí en el camino porque realmente
era natural en mí hacerlo y lograr es
que yo te puedo dejar un mensaje una
idea que valga la pena
compartir en esta noche es busca tu
talento tu fórmula personal del éxito de
vida de profesión de cómo quieres
generar riqueza de cómo quieres impactar
la vida de otros de cómo quieres ser
recordado y reconocido identifica tu
talento buscan aférrate a él desarrolla
lo al máximo y te aseguro que eso sí
será tu fórmula personal del éxito